que va-t-on bien pouvoir manger ce soir
mangez un acte apparemment basiques que
nous connaissons tous depuis que nous
sommes arrivés sur terre mais se nourrir
est un phénomène bien naturel ça veut
pas dire qu'un phénomène naturel ne veux
pas être un phénomène complexe en raison
de nombreuses injonctions croyances
habitude bien manger déjà paraît
compliqué bien manger manger beaux
engins gourmands
manger sain manger équilibré manger les
chais manger toujours manger en fait
manger est un acte unique privé et même
intime vital pour certains perte de
temps pour d'autres politique historique
gastronomique parfois culturelles
parfois social bio ou industriel local
ou mondial
en mode cloud ou fast good juste a qu'à
observer quelqu'un mange et on a tout de
suite déjà un panel de sa personnalité
alors aujourd'hui manger est un acte
teintées d'information et d'émotion mais
il fut une époque où se nourrir était
simplement un acte de survie
aujourd'hui nous pourrions imaginer nous
sommes plus dans la soul vie alors
comment être uniquement simplement temps
la vie
reprenons un instant le fil de
l'histoire manger est un acte pour soit
d'accord en tant qu'adulte c'est bien
moi qui décide de mon autonomie de mon
indépendance
ok c'est bien moi qui décide chaque jour
d'introduire dans mon corps de la
nourriture jeudi introduire c'est exprès
que j'utilise ce verbe introduire de la
nourriture parce qu'il ya une entrée
pour cette nourriture enfin nous ce
carburant
tiens en parlant de carburant parfois
ils ne sont pas très adapté là après le
fondant au chocolat il fallait un café
et puis un petit digestif mais enfin une
bonne sieste
parce que
je sais pas vous mais moi parfois
j'essaie de faire attention de pas me
tromper de carburant quand je fais le
plein dans ma voiture
il viendrait pas à l'idée d'utiliser de
la bière sans gluten ou du jus de pomme
quand je fais le plein parfois je
pourrais même être exigeant et calculer
les performances en notant les
kilomètres que je vais parcourir avec se
plaint pour être efficace évidemment
alors faire ça avec un corps humain
ça semble déjà beaucoup plus compliqué
et c'est là que je me rends compte que
je ne connais pas mon véhicule
enfin mon véhicule mon corps quoi vous
l'aurez compris si j'ai besoin d'être
performant dans ma journée d'être
efficace quel type de carburant
pardon quel type de nourriture je vais
utiliser la qualité la quantité de
quelle manière je vais manger cette
nourriture
voilà pourquoi introduire de la
nourriture dans son corps est un acte
intime
lorsque je me connecte à cette
nourriture à ce carburant
je pourrais imaginer des tas de mots qui
me viennent neuneu n'imaginez pas le
nombre de mots qui me viennent
il ya des dictionnaires sur la
nourriture on n'a jamais autant parlé de
nourriture le nombre d'expressions qui
nous parle de nourriture tenez je vous
raconte une petite histoire
au début je les dévorer des yeux elle et
échoue gens m'appellent l'eau à la
bouche
mais rapidement je me suis rendu compte
que je n'allais pas digéré ce qu'elle
m'a dit vous imaginez elle m'a dit moi
haut comme trois pommes avec ma tronche
de cake je mâche mes mots et en plus je
mange sur le pouce et je bouffe à tous
les râteliers choisir en conscience ces
aliments
c'est bien un acte intime ok ça rentre
ça sort alors autant que le voyage soit
sympa vous ne trouvez pas et oui quand
je pense à cette expression
comment ça va en version plus polis
comment allez vous on attribue cette
expression au moyen âge même si elle a
des origines incertaines
ce que l'on sait
c'est que cette expression est un
raccourci de comment ça va aux toilettes
comment allez-vous à la selle et oui au
moyen-âge avec l'introduction de la
médecine grand public
c'est un indicateur essentiel et unique
pour connaître l'état de santé
donc nous allons vraisemblablement aller
voir la consistance et l'odeur de la
petite défection ouah tout un programme
aujourd'hui encore si je suis bien dans
mon corps je suis bien dans ma vie si je
mange bien je digère bien
j'évacue bien je suis bien
regardons-nous comme adultes c'est
tellement important et essentiel pour
nous que nos enfants soient propres
car c'est le chemin de l'autonomie et
parfois nous les adultes nous semblons
comme figé dans nos têtes comme coupé de
nos ressentis alors là chacun y va de
ses conseils avisés
ah si tu n'es pas bien tu devrais manger
telle manière ou moitessier depuis je
mange ses graines là je vais mieux
essaye moi franchement depuis que je
mange bio je fais des cacas bio
difficile pour quelqu'un qui aimeraient
bien manger ou mieux manger de s'y
retrouver
moi je suis cuisinier et devant mes
clients je doit définir le type
d'alimentation que je prépare alors
parfois j'utilise des mots et je parle
d'alimentation santé alimentation saine
et là parfois les gens en face de moi me
dise en et moi vous savez je me mange
sain comme s'il se sentait attaquée
c'est vrai que nous recevons beaucoup
d'informations ce qui est bon ce qui est
moins bon ce qui est nocif
qui croire quoi croit alors si on parle
d'alimentation santé cela veut dire
qu'il ya une alimentation non santé et
là je parle de l'industrie agro
alimentaire
je parle de l'aspartame je parle de la
réionisation de la mondialisation de
l'agriculture intensive de
l'introduction du lait en poudre de la
stimulation de la récompense
je pense aussi aux édulcorants au
glutamate monosodique je pense au sucre
en poudre
enfin le sucre vous savez le truc légal
je sais pas si ça vous dit quelque chose
bref toute une panoplie de choses nous
ont comme séparer de notre véritable
nature alors en prenant un peu de recul
une alimentation santé enfin une
alimentation qui est censé préserver la
santé
cela veut juste simplement dire que nous
nous nourrissons avec des apports qui
sont en adéquation avec ce le camp avec
ce que le corps a besoin dans des danses
et besoins physiologiques les réels
besoins du corps dans une perspective
holistique
nous pourrions imaginer qu'il n'y a pas
de bon ou de mauvais produits une
nourriture est un collier avec celui qui
la mange
peut-être que cela n'a aucun sens de
recommander 2500 calories par jour pour
un homme si nous ne connaissons pas cet
homme
dans quel état émotionnel est il donc l
énergie mangent-ils que mon style parce
que sa nourriture et cuites et crues
quelle qualité quelle quantité tout est
à relier avec son terrain va son terrain
oui pareil on a tous un terrain tout
terrain alors là je pourrais vous parler
du terrain sur lequel mes tomates
poussent puis vous dire ben oui la
qualité du sol il ya des petits verres
de terre il ya de la vie c'est vivant il
ya des organismes il ya des des enzymes
qui a des bactéries ya des trucs qui
grouillent là il ya des trucs vivant
alors ces trucs vivent ils sont dans
tous les terrains alors moi je suis une
bactérie sur pattes c'est ça si nous
sommes constitués en majorité d'eau cet
ol est bien vivant non si je reviens à
mon terrain dans quel état est il eh
bien je n'en sais rien
alors une direction à prendre serait me
semble-t-il de se réapproprier ces
métiers d'acteurs de réalisateurs
d'auteur de ce film que nous faisons sur
le rapport à notre
notation et pour cela selon moi cela
passe par se faire confiance reprendre
confiance en soi pour savoir quand et
quoi manger pour certains se nourrir est
perçu comme un réel combat intérieur un
vrai combat peut-être que il n'y aurait
tout simplement rien à combattre se
faire confiance
cela passe par connaître ses goûts et
ses envies savez vous que parfois
certaines personnes me disent qu'ils ne
savent pas ce qu'ils aiment alors au
lieu de tester et d'expérimenter avec
leur corps ils restent dans la tête
et savez vous qu'il ya cette maladie
qu'on appelle orthorexie qui concerne
notre attitude vis-à-vis de la
nourriture et de l'ingestion d'une
manière obsessionnelle de nourriture
perçu comme scène et le rejet
systématique des aliments qui sont
perçues comme malsain
si vous ne savez pas comment vous relier
à cette confiance et oui on nous allons
parler d'intuition quand je fais une
première fois la recette
moi personnellement je pourrais me dire
je les fais de manière intuitive
d'autres pourraient dire oh mais moi
j'ai besoin absolument de connaître la
recette une première fois de
l'expérimenté de me l'approprier pour
ensuite la transformer à ta sauce elles
étaient vraiment bonnes qu'est ce que tu
as mis dedans
euh je sais pas c'était très intuitif
pour certains cela paraît inaccessible
alors une piste selon moi à suivre c'est
ce souvenir de ce que nous aimions
manger quand nous étions petit les
textures les saveurs les couleurs les
goûts parce que j'aimais manger avec les
doigts
quels souvenirs j'ai de cette période où
mon être intérieur mon enfant était
largement connecter à naissance à cette
vibration d'être vivant à cette joie
d'être un enfant tout simplement quel
goût à ce monde
souvenez vous les enfants mettent tous à
la bouche la bouche c'est bien
l'interface entre le monde extérieur le
monde intérieur
quelle joie de goûter les cailloux de
saliver les crayons de mâchonner les
brins d'herbe ou de croquer les clés de
voiture l'enfant et vibrant il teste
il est connecté à ses ressentis quel
goût à ce monde alors une autre piste à
suivre aussi me semble-t-il pourrait
être de lâcher les étiquettes des
étiquettes qui nous enferment aller au
delà des mots oui une étiquette une
étiquette politique culturelle une
étiquette professionnels le ticket de
social une étiquette alimentaire
parfaite pour nous rassurer et nous
catégoriser l'étiquette alimentaires
parfois pourrait être une piste réelle
à suivre il se peut que j'aie besoin de
partager de comprendre d'expérimenter et
là je me rapproche de communautés
alimentaire vegan flex ivg omni palais
aux mangeurs de graines cru dit moi
j'étais dans la macro biot quand j'étais
petit toute une catégorie de et de
panoplies de mots qui nous enferment il
ya quelques semaines j'ai partagé et
j'ai créé un repas dans une famille nous
avons réalisé une soupe ou un velouté
bref un délicieux bol et la maman dit
hors fameuse fameuse votre volonté et
son fils dit maman c'est pas un goûter
c'est une crème et là la petite soeur 10
95 millions ok nous avons tous le même
bol délicieux devant nous et les mots ou
sépare savez vous que votre corps n'est
pas passif il vit il vibre il est en
recherche permanente des deux
d'harmonie il est en quête d' équilibre
il est votre vraie boussole alors si
vous catégoriser votre vie comment
rester connecté aux évolutions de ce que
vous allez ressentir dans votre corps
comment rester souple et flexible face
aux saison intérieure à tous les âges de
la vie et à tous ce rythme dans votre
journée et dans votre vie quotidienne
ressentir pleinement
cela passe par le corps donc si nous
pouvons lâché la tête
nous allons pouvoir vivre c'est saison
intérieure avec joie c'est aussi une
manière d'apprendre à sentir
différemment si je lâche l'étiquette je
lâche la catégorie je vais apprendre à
sentir je vais apprendre ce que j'aime
je vais apprendre les besoins je vais me
connecter à mais réel besoin
je vais pouvoir sentir ce dont j'ai
besoin
donner envie à mes enfants de faire la
même chose motorisé le meilleur autorisé
le meilleur autour de moi et grandir de
cela une réelle aide aujourd'hui hélas
nous ne pouvons pas nous tromper c'est
de regarder les grandes lois du vivant
les grands principes de la vie
si je regarde comment marche le vivant
et qu'à un moment je me sens évolué je
me sens grandir j'ai envie d'évoluer
dans ma vie je ne peux pas me tromper
car si je regarde le vivant je ne peux
que me sentir vivant et là une infinité
de promesses s'ouvre devant vous à
chaque instant à chaque minute à chaque
journée tout est vivant en vous et c'est
une danse de la vie qui commence
et là j'apprends un petit peu plus avoir
confiance en moi
tiens est ce que je me respecte quand
j'ai envie de manger un petit dessert
pour prolonger le moment de qualité avec
mes amis est ce que j'ose léché
l'assiette tu crois parce que la société
vraiment trop bonne il n'y a pas que les
femmes enceintes qui ont droit
d'assouvir leurs besoins de gourmandise
est ce que j'ose aller plus loin et je
me respecte vraiment donc qui je suis à
tous les instants de ma journée
pour cela je dois connaître mes besoins
il est certain je vous invite à sentir
ces énergies d'abondance de vie qui nous
entourent et qui sont en jeu vous invite
à apprendre à aller un petit peu plus
loin connecter à vos réels besoins
profonds de quoi j'ai envie maintenant
cela passe par une connaissance de soi
il est certain lorsque je me connecte à
moi même je me connecte à l'autre si je
me respecte
je respecte l'autre je crée donc un
monde meilleur
c'est super ça on va créer un monde de
rêve incroyable
tous ces mots c'est bien mais comment
fait-on concrètement comment fait-on
lorsque je me connecte à mes sensations
ma vie a du sens lorsque je vis avec du
sens mais sans sont en ébullition
je parle en termes de sensationnel de
sensations de sensuel sensuelle du latin
qui a rapport au sens lorsque je me
connecte à mes sens tout fait sens et
lorsque je ne sais plus dans quelle
direction aller dans ma vie dans quel
sens
beaucoup d'informations peuvent arriver
à ce moment là si je suis ouvert à cela
uniquement si je suis ouvert à cela tous
nous parle de sensations dans notre vie
d'êtres humains nous faisons constamment
des choix en fonction des sensations que
nous pensons obtenir
il n'y a pas besoin d'être un sportif de
l'extrême
le sportif de l'extrême se frotte à des
sensations à ses propres limites pour
pour sentir pulsé la vie en lui mais
nous lorsque je vais boire un verre avec
des amis lorsque je vais faire du sport
ou que j'écoute de la musique lorsque je
choisis la destination de mes prochaines
vacances
tout est fait en fonction des sensations
que je pense obtenir les sensations
comme je vous le disais sont au coeur de
la vie humaine
et là je parle en termes d'êtres humains
d'être vivant en termes d'un animal qui
sent d'ailleurs certains sont très bons
pour avoir du flair et sentir les bonnes
affaires
une phrase que j'aime beaucoup c'est
le nez ne réfléchit pas il se jette dans
l'aventuré alors lorsque je me connecte
à mes sensations lorsque je connais je
me connecte à skis et vivent en moi tout
est possible tout un univers de
promesses s'ouvre à moi plus aucune
limite
je peut grandir en évoluant à chaque
instant de la vie en choisissant en
conscience de me nourrir avec amour tout
un programme
et quel joli programme la prochaine fois
que vous mangez
ouvrez vos sens jouer essayer vivait
nourrissez-vous d'amour oser oser vivre
aussi vibrer alors mon invitation
lâchement la tête connectons nous à nos
sensations qui font sens soyons vivants
et gourmand belle aventure à vous merci
[Applaudissements]